ende
ich wurde angefragt das einer und eine
kabeltrommel gekommen ist sie haben
nicht seiner mitarbeiter des trommlers
umgefallen und der mitarbeiter ist da
und die trommel geraten
ich habe noch kann ich mich noch genau
erinnert sagt okay ich verständigt
sofort die rettung
sie sollen einfach ruhig sein einstellen
war es ja wie ihr ruf der schweiz gibt
es nicht
sind alle fix und fertig gewesen und
haben auch geweint
es ist ein fachkollege und west zu
müssen vorstellen
das ist nicht von meinem jeden tag
zusammen ist mit jemand auf einmal
passiert so etwas fürchterliches das ist
auch nicht so einfach weiß dass man
damit umgeht
der libro ag hat es gern in die per
dekret das in das er durch so wenig
verdient du bist ganz gut
und jetzt schaut erst einmal mehr
verdienst dass du wusstest du mir
vielleicht war ja heißen der auszuweiten
und dadurch dass dafür dienst holz und
silber heute aufsichten american
songbook und uns gleich ging es heute
auch sehr von herz gehende saison was
den sohn hat einmal gesagt und erzählt
auch danach freizeit hoppla das auto in
die berge rung gewesen weist das ist
sein leben war das